Unter dem kilometerdicken Eisschild der Antarktis
befindet sich eine Welt, über die bislang
kaum etwas bekannt ist.
Jetzt ist es einem internationalen Forschungsteam
gelungen, ein 1000 Meter tiefes Loch zu graben
und dabei einen See anzubohren, der direkt
unter einem Gletscher liegt.
Ein Wahnsinns-Unterfangen!
Und nicht nur das: Dabei wurden mehr als unerwartete
Funde gemacht!
Wie genau die aufwendige Bohrung gelang und
ob in dem finsteren See auch die ein oder
andere unentdeckte Spezies aufgespürt werden
konnte, erfahrt ihr jetzt bei Clixoom Science
& Fiction - hier gibt es jeden Tag spannende
Wissenschaftsvideos.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts.
Herzlich willkommen!
Nicht nur das Weltall birgt noch viele unentdeckte
Überraschungen für uns, sondern auch die
Antarktis.
Denn unter dem kilometerdicken Eis gibt es
zahlreiche Gebiete, die uns bislang noch völlig
unbekannt sind.
Was ist dort verborgen?
Welche Prozesse finden unter dem antarktischen
Eisschild ab?
Wie sieht es dort aus und wie kann man sich
die Strömung des Wassers vorstellen?
Höchstwahrscheinlich verbergen sich in diesen
unerforschten Regionen zudem auch Organismen,
von denen wir bislang nicht einmal etwas ahnen.
Nicht umsonst hat die wissenschaftliche Fachzeitschrift
“Nature” die Welt unter dem ewigen Eis
der Antarktis einmal als das “größte unerforschte
Ökosystem des Planeten” benannt.
Denn um in die entsprechenden Tiefen zu gelangen,
sind tagelange Bohrungen notwendig.
Doch einem internationalen Forschungsteam
ist jetzt ein entscheidender Erfolg gelungen,
der uns hilft, mehr über diese mysteriösen
Gebiete unserer Erde zu erfahren.
Ende Dezember war es geschafft: Mehrere Tage
lang hatten sich ein Hochdruck- und Heißwasserbohrer
durch eine knapp 1.100 Meter dicke Eisschicht
gearbeitet.
Das Forschungsteam hatte die dafür benötigte
500 Tonnen schwere Ausrüstung zuvor zwei
Monate lang zu der abgelegenen Stelle im Süden
der Antarktis transportiert.
Doch die ganze Arbeit war nicht umsonst: Denn
bei den Bohrungen 600 Kilometer vom Südpol
entfernt erreichte das Forschungsteam den
antarktischen subglazialen See namens “Lake
Mercer”.
Er hat eine Fläche von 160 Quadratkilometern
und ist dabei doppelt so groß wie Manhattan.
Seine Tiefe wird auf zehn bis 15 Meter geschätzt.
Und dieses Unterfangen ist ein riesiger Erfolg.
Denn das ist überhaupt erst das zweite Mal
in der Geschichte der Menschheit, das solch
ein subglazialen See, also ein See unter einem
Gletscher, direkt angebohrt werden konnte.
Zwar konnten schon in den 90er Jahren per
Radar Seen und Flüsse unter der Eisschicht
aufgespürt werden, von denen wohl einige
seit 120.000 Jahren von der Außenwelt abgeschnitten
sind.
Dennoch weiß man bis heute kaum etwas über
diese Gebiete.
Solche Seen entstehen wohl, weil die Erdkruste
wärmer ist als die Eisdecke, die darüber
liegt.
Das Gestein fungiert also als eine Art Wärmequelle
und sorgt dafür, dass die Eisdecke von unten
schmilzt. 2013 gelang eine Bohrung eines anderen
subglazialen See, der sogenannte “Lake Whillans”.
Die Untersuchungen zeigten, dass trotz der
extremen Bedingungen dort unten reichlich
mikrobielles Leben möglich ist.
Anzeichen für höheres Leben fand sich damals
aber nicht.
Entsprechend gespannt waren die Fachleute
auch, was die Analyse ihrer Proben diesmal
ergeben würde.
Und auch diesmal gelang es dem internationalen
Forschungsteam mit viel Mühe, durch den gebohrten
Schacht im Eis eine Wasserprobe zu entnehmen.
Und tatsächlich: Auch in den eisigen Gewässern
des “Lake Mercer” lauern unzählige Organismen.
Dazu David Harwood, einer der beteiligten
Wissenschaftler: “Meine Aufgabe in dem Projekt
ist es, nach fossilen Überresten von Kieselalgen
zu suchen.
Die sollten aus der Zeit stammen, als sich
das Eis zurückgezogen hatte und das Meer
weit in die Westantarktis vorgedrungen war.
Als ich im Schlamm nach diesen Kieselalgen
suchte, entdeckte ich darin auch die Überreste
eines Panzers, der aussah wie von einem winzigen
Krebstier.
Das Chitin des Panzers war gealtert, fleckig
und dunkel.“
Die Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
konnten also nicht nur Mikroben und Kieselalgen
aufspüren, sondern auch Spuren von winzigen
Tieren, Pilzen und Pflanzen.
Dieser Fund von Krebstierchen und Bärtierchen,
sogenannten Tardigrada, überraschte das Forschungsteam
allerdings selbst.
Auch, wenn alle Tiere in den bislang analysierten
Proben tot waren, kann es laut Angaben der
Fachleute gut sein, dass dort sich dort unten
auch lebende Organismen befinden.
Wahnsinn.
Die große Frage: Wie konnten diese komplexen
Organismen in das eisig kalte und dunkle Gewässer
kommen und wie können sie dort in den bitterkalten
Seen ohne Sonnenlicht überleben?!
Dazu gibt es bisher nur Vermutungen.
Vor mehreren Millionen Jahren war das Eis
über “Lake Mercer” noch ein Meer: damals
haben wohl die nun aufgespürten Kieselalgen
in dieser Region gelebt.
Die Bärtierchen und Krebse sind dem Forschungsteam
zufolge wohl wesentlich jünger und haben
vor einigen tausend bis zehntausend Jahren
in Tümpeln, die sich in dem umliegenden Gebirge
befinden, gelebt.
Wie sie dann genau in den See gelangt sind,
ist bisher noch unklar.
Denkbar sei, dass die Meerestiere eingespült
worden seien, als das antarktische Eis dünner
war, so das Forschungsteam.
Später habe sie das Eisschild dann in den
vereisten Seen eingeschlossen.
Eine endgültige Antwort auf dieses Rätsel
könnten jedoch nur weitere Analysen im Labor
geben: Haben die Bär- und Krebstierchen tatsächlich
kilometer tief im dunklen Eis gelebt?!
Das Autorenteam der aktuellen Studie geht
jedenfalls davon aus, dass das Überleben
dieser Organismen unter dem Eis der Antarktis
theoretisch möglich ist.
Die Lebewesen könnten sich von Bakterien
und Sauerstoff ernährt haben, der wohl in
ausreichendem Maß enthalten sei.
Die genaue Analyse und Interpretation der
gesammelten Proben wird wahrscheinlich noch
einige Jahre dauern.
Doch die Chancen stehen gut, das wir dadurch
Lebensformen besser verstehen können, die
seit Jahrhunderten die Sonne nicht mehr gesehen
haben.
Auch zum Verständnis der antarktischen Geschichte
wird dieses Unterfangen sicherlich beitragen.
Und ausgeschlossen ist auch nicht, dass auch
noch die ein ander andere unentdeckte Spezies
aufgespürt wird, die sich seit unzähligen
Jahren unter der dicken Eisschicht verbirgt.
Dazu der Wissenschaftler John Priscu: “ ” Zudem
kann man diese Biosphäre mit potentiellen
Lebensräumen tief im Mars oder auf den eisbedeckten
Monden von Saturn und Jupiter vergleichen.
Also den Lebensräumen, wo wir außerirdisches
Leben vermuten oder es theoretisch existieren
könnte oder Überreste davon.
Die Erkenntnisse des Mercer-Sees könnten
somit also auch spannende Indizien dafür
liefern, welche Art von Leben auf Planeten
in unserem Sonnensystem existieren könnten.
Und wie man sie sucht, erfahrt ihr bei Raumzeit
Vlog der Zukunft im Video dafür hier drauf
klicken: Wie man Außerirdische sucht - die
10 realistischsten Methoden. also unbedingt
anklicken und natürlich abonnieren, falls
ihr es noch nicht getan habt.
Ansonsten: Bis dann, bleibt dran!